We created our data task, but
print statement is not executing.
What's going on?
Well, the problem is the NSURL session
doesn't directly run tasks for us.
Instead it gives us methods to create
tasks, but then we're responsible for
starting them ourselves.
Now, this may seem tedious, but it
actually gives us much more flexibility
for starting, stopping,
and resuming tasks.
To start the task, we just need to call
the resume method on the task itself.
Now let's run this.
>> There we go, now that's the print
statement we were expecting.
The next step will be to take the data
that's Its a completion handler and
create an image that we
can display to the user.
Let's look at Apple's documentation for
the data task with URL
completion handler method.
In the discussion section,
there's this one really important
blur that I want to focus on.
It says, If the request completes
successfully, the data parameter of
the completion handler block
contains the resource data.
And the air parameter's nil, but if the
request fails the data parameter is nil,
and air parameter contains
information about the failure.
So back in the code we can use this
information to our advantage and
check first to see if the air is nil.
As long as the air is nill then
our data should be good to use.
Now, how can we take our data, which is
in the form of an NS data object, and
turn it into an image
that we can display?
Actually, it's quite easy.
The UI image class has a handy
initializer that can construct an image
directly from NS data.
So we'll use it to create an image.
And then we'll set the image views
image property to our downloaded image.
This looks great,
let's run it and see if it works.
>> Well, somethings wrong again,
we're not getting our image.
Let me try something else,
since I have a little experience
dealing with these kind of problems.
In the simulator, I'm going to
simulate hitting the home button.
The hot key for
this is command shift h, there we go.
Or you can select it from
the simulator's toolbar here at the top.
There it is, home button.
This takes us out of the app.
Now, let's reopen it.
There's our image.
How come it didn't show up at first?
Let's investigate this problem next.